by the care minister helen waitley as
well good to have you on as always
and uh of course loads to talk about on
on your brief specifically but before we
do
i i think we just need to reflect that
which we were hearing about the
hospitality sector
businesses in the nighttime economy have
an average made you know almost
40 percent of their staff redundant what
what support is going to be available to
the nighttime sector
when the economy does eventually reopen
i mean
it's clearly absolutely true to say that
uh hospitality sector
nighttime sector has been so hard hit
by the pandemic and by the restrictions
i mean
what we know is already there's been a
package of 280 billion pounds worth of
support to the economy
from the chancellor from the government
and as of next week on monday the prime
minister's going to be setting out
the plan for how we come out of lockdown
so to me that's a really important thing
for us to be step by step step and doing
this cautiously
of course because we want this to be the
last ever national lockdown
but step by step for us to be taking
forward um
coming coming out of these restrictions
firstly getting
children back to school but in due
course opening up hospitality
and getting back to life more like
normal i i suppose part of the problem
has been of course the government having
finite resources and determining where
they were to go you know before the
vaccine rollout started it was very
difficult to see
how the nighttime economies could get
back to anything approaching
normality i mean you appeared on the
show back at the tail end of september
you know said the following
it doesn't make sense to continue
supporting jobs where
there simply isn't work at the moment
was that though perhaps an oversight
given the fact that we have seen almost
four in 10 workers in that sector losing
their jobs
well as i said i think you know the
important thing
is that in the weeks and months ahead we
take the steps to come out of lockdown
to move on from the restrictions that
we've had to have over
the the last you know months most of the
last year and
we've we're in a much much better place
now we've had nearly 16 million people
vaccinated that's a huge deal we have an
enormous testing capacity as well
and we've learned a huge amount about
the virus we've got better treatments
for it as well
um so i see us being in a much better
place as we come through this but we
will of course hear more from the prime
minister on monday
yeah a huge deal and indeed a huge
achievement of course and
uh the roots out of all of this though
is is of course where the focus is and
specifics will come on monday but
i understand that but as you said we all
want this to be the last
national lockdown the signal from
central government has been that we want
to be
relaxing things on a national basis
some suggest you know in the papers this
morning that that if there were to be an
outbreak we could see a return to
localized
lockdown conditions what's your view in
there
well i'd say probably wait until next
week until
uh when the prime minister sets out that
road map for how we're going to come
through it
um but we have clearly learned a huge
amount we learned during the summer
about
how to manage localized outbreaks and
take that approach
um but i i don't really want to preempt
what we're going to hear next week
sure i thought i thought that might well
be the response um well let's let's talk
about schools are we of course
uh march the eighth big date from for
many many people
not least not least the parents in all
of this and again we know that testing
in schools is going to be
is going to be part of the way we move
out of all of this but we're now being
told that
we could be seeing teachers in secondary
schools administering
one set of tests and then the
responsibility being put on to the
parents
at least for for secondary school
students
well first i mean i like like many uh
thousands of parents i'm really looking
forward to when schools go back i've
got three children at home homeschooling
and
i think as all of us know who are doing
that it's not the easy things
thing to do and gives you even more
respect than you already had for
the teachers who usually uh teach your
children in fact have been doing an
amazing job providing online support
during
the pandemic um so you know we're
looking forward to
the plan is for schools to be able to
start going back on the 8th of march
and again next week more will be set out
about how the return to school is going
to work
i i understand that but one thing we can
say with certainty is you know from that
react study that's out at the moment
clearly some of the greatest
transmission that is taking place or the
highest amount of transmission that's
taking place is
is taking place in children it is taking
place in younger people
now that may well be a result of the
fact that they're not in school that
they're associating at home
but does that not give any pause for
concern does that give any pause ahead
of the decision to reopen schools on
march 8th
well i mean what has been clear is that
we will look at the data
and the reason why we have put off
saying what the roadmap is going to be
until next week was to make sure that we
had time
to look at the data to to know that we
have vaccinated so many people to be
able to look at the impact
of the national lockdown on rates to
also
see how that has enabled hospitals to be
in a better position to cope
and there's one reason why a level of
caution is being counseled
to to recognize the lockdown is going to
we're going to come out of it step by
step
because we still have over 20 000 people
in hospital
we've covered we still had over a
thousand new admissions on saturday for
example
so no this isn't over yet though we have
this fantastic situation we're in of
nearly 16 million people
vaccinated the vaccination program going
at such a tremendous pace and there's a
brilliant job being done by the nhs and
by volunteers some of them i've
met who are supporting the vaccine
program but we are going to have to take
the step by step but what we've always
said is we're determined to bring back
schools
as quickly as we can because we know
that
being out of school is not the good
thing for children's education it's so
much better for children to be in school
and that's really important that we try
and get that to happen i mean tell us a
little bit minister about the additional
funding
that's going to be made available for
for looking at long covered i mean
clearly it is a condition of concern for
for all of us
but particularly of course for those
people who've been working on the front
line and have contracted covert through
you know doing their job and looking
after the rest of us
oh you're absolutely right and i mean
what we're seeing is about one in ten
people
uh suffering from some form of long
covet so having
some symptoms that go on for three
months or more quite a range of symptoms
um but you know some are really making a
really tough to
live with and so we need to understand
more about this uh illness and how long
covered affects people and also how to
treat people and support people that's
one reason why today we're announcing
18 million pounds more going into
research
into long covered and exactly that how
we can help support people and treat
people and help people through it
i i'm part of the reason minister of
course that i mentioned those working on
the front lines
some really interesting data out today
about people applying to become
nurses nursing applications are in fact
up by a third
you know i've got to say slightly
surprising to me that in the middle of a
viral pandemic you know people
are wanting to go out there and help but
actually perhaps it's not desperately
surprising the british public
are running together well i think you
you put it exactly right there and i'm
really glad that you've brought this
up that um we're seeing from the ucas
figures out today that we've had a
third up a third increase of
applications to study nursing
degrees um so we've had nearly 50 000
people apply to study nursing
already to start this autumn which is
tremendous news for
for me with oversight the nhs workforce
it's a really big deal because i want us
to make sure we have
more nurses that we have the workforce
that we need and we have 50 000
more nurses coming to the nhs by the end
of this parliament so
this is really important for the nhs but
exactly as you say it's a real
reflection
on how people have seen the fantastic
job that the nhs and actually social
care workers have done
throughout this pandemic and want to
step up and join them
and we've got that sense of public
service of commitment of wanting to help
others
so overall i think it's really really
good news and a real testament to
how our health and social care system
has been coping in this pandemic
yeah i mean of course another another
sector and one that you're directly
responsible for
that we need to see more people going
into is of course them the care
professions i mean
we learned yesterday and i know this
will be frustrating to you
but we learned yesterday that the social
care plan you know that boris johnson
promised back when he was
became prime minister in july 2019 has
again
somewhat been kicked into the long grass
no action being taken on that as i
understand it
until at least the end of the year can
you just provide some reassurance to
those
who have family members in care homes
who are perhaps working
in social care themselves that we are
actually going to start doing this at
some point because
you know the party has been in power
since 2010 and we have had
a number of promises on social care
everyone understands pandemics get in
the way of things
but it does feel like once again social
care is not where it should be
absolutely and i remember it was it was
roughly a year ago that the prime
minister asked me to take on the job of
being care minister
and then the job was very much going to
be driving forward our ambitions for
social care reform
then we've had the pandemic and
inevitably we've had to focus
all our resources and attention um on
on helping social care through this
really really difficult time
but we are absolutely determined that
we're going to take forward social care
reform there is work going on on this
we're going to come out with our
plan during the course of this year
we've seen
absolutely that the social care system
needs it it's been really tough for
social care to get through this pandemic
and so no i'm determined that coming
through this we will get to a better
place for social care
and make sure we get to a care system
that everybody knows is going to be
there for them and give them the care
that they need
and also as part of that make sure that
we really give the social care workforce
the recognition and the support that
they deserve for the really tough job
but actually really rewarding job that
they are doing too
well look people are are waiting for
that and they're eagerly waiting for
that and they have been they have been
eagerly waiting for for quite some time
but just one last question on care homes
um 95
i think absolutely the end of the end of
january about 95
of care home residents had had their
first vaccine what is the earliest
possible moment that people will be able
to go and see their relatives in care
homes
i really really want to open up visiting
in care homes more i mean to be clear
we have made sure that visiting can
continue even during this national
lockdown
but i recognize it's not the normal kind
of visiting it's having to use screens
or visiting codes or
through windows if care homes don't have
those facilities i will say we have put
funding
into social care to help care homes have
these facilities
and have extra staff if they need to
supervise
but what i want to do as we come out of
the national lockdown is
also increase the amount of visiting
um i don't see that we have to wait for
the second vaccination
dose i want us to open up sooner than
that but i will say with this as with
generally as we come out of lockdown
we do have to be cautious um say
residents most residents in camps have
only had their first dose and some of
them
only very recently so it will be step by
step but i'm determined
so that we can see people you know go
back to to know even if it's to be able
to hold hands again and to see somebody
who you haven't been able to see very
much in the last few months um
i know but last year i really want to
make that happen again
minister i know we've got to let you go
but just for clarity when you say second
dose do you mean second dose for
all of us are second those for care home
residents i meant for recurring
residents
great thank you minister great to have
you on the program thank you